movies mean everything i owe
movies my my life one of the most
intimate relationships i have in my life
is with film when i was growing up i was
raised by a single mother and so that
meant i was home alone a lot and movies
became my escape my mom started me
watching old movies when there was one
channel that had an old movie every day
movies didn't just teach me about the
world and were the fairy tales of my
youth but also gave me a voice a lot of
what i learned in my experience through
life is through film it really helped me
escape from bad moments to feel better
it was comforting but it also inspired
me to be confident enough that i could
achieve my dreams i got to learn about
the world and about subjects that could
be brought right into my living room but
movies in general i just it feels like
to me it's it's the way sort of chapter
marks in where we are in culture where
we are as a country where as a world
when raising in the sun i was just in my
teenage years
none of us really ever see a black man
move like city 48 not in hollywood films
there's nothing like a great story told
well acted well the storytelling art
really illuminates the side of humanity
it helps us understand who we are better
you know storytelling to me feels like
one of the main reasons why we are even
still here as a species and that's the
beauty about stories they could be from
any part of the world the emotions are
pretty much the same and that's what
keeps us linked i get to do what i love
and at the same time grow as a human
being through what i love and i really
couldn't ask for much more movies are
getting to experience the greatest
pleasure i've ever known so
movies i love you
you